PROFESSOR: So now
that we've talked
about the different dynamics
of droplets in the air,
we can think about how
different types of pathogen
can leverage those
droplets to transmit
from one person to another
through respiration
through the air.
So let's begin with bacteria.
So there are many different
kinds of bacteria.
The typical size of
a single bacterium
is on the order of
several microns.
So let's just say,
1 to 10 microns.
On the other hand,
bacteria can also
exist in colonies or
larger structures.
And that does determine,
to some extent,
what kinds of droplets can
transmit those bacteria.
So let's begin with an
example of a large-drop
bacteria, which
is typically going
to be found in large drops.
And that would be
the bacteria that
causes strep throat,
the streptococcus.
So the streptococcus
bacteria, which is shown here,
has a typical size that's
around two microns.
So it's on the smaller end.
And it forms chains and
even larger colonies they
may have different structures.
And the total size
of the colonies
can vary to be as big
as even 500 microns.
So it may not be always
that big, but it might be,
let's say, 50 to 500
micron sort of colonies.
And they can often be these
sort of stringy type structures.
As a result, those require
fairly large droplets.
Now just simply knowing
that we have large droplet,
tells us a lot about how this
bacteria can actually transmit
and what measures must
be taken against it.
Because as soon as we have
large drops, then what it means
is that we have fast settling.
So we know drops that
are in this size range
are going to fall to the
ground within a few seconds.
And even if you cough them
with a lot of big velocity --
which is something we'll
talk about later in this
and these lectures --
then still, in
only a few seconds
those droplets can sediment
out and they really
don't go very far.
OK?
And so they're fast-settling.
And so what that
means is that we have
either fomite transmission,
where those droplets
settle on the ground,
or on some other surface --
somebody touches that
surface, touches their eyes --
and so that's one
method of transmission.
We could also have direct
airborne transmission.
Where let's say, I
cough or breathe on you.
And the droplets end up in
your face and maybe directly
on your eyes,
or maybe you breathe them in --
so there could be also
direct airborne transmission
for some of the
smaller sized droplets
or for large droplets which are
ejected from let's, say a cough
or something.
And so what that means,
that the way that we protect
against bacterial
transmission of disease
is, for example,
for the fomites,
we will disinfect surfaces.
We can wash hands, of course.
And we will avoid
touching eyes or nose.
So those are pretty
basic measures.
At the same time,
if we're worried
about the direct
transmission of the droplets
from especially coughing or
sneezing larger droplets,
then what else can we do?
Well, we can have
plastic shields.
Either worn over
the face or maybe
a barrier between yourself and
some other person that you're
interacting with to avoid that
sort of projectile transmission
of large droplets.
And also, we will get
the six-foot rule.
Which is just an example of
a social distancing measure,
which is recommended
to avoid this sort
of direct airborne transmission.
Again, coming back to the
idea that droplets of the size
typically settle
in a few seconds.
And if you look at the typical
velocities of ejection,
especially from
coughs and sneezes,
then they will settle in about
six feet or so or about two
meters.
Although that's not a hard rule.
The six-foot rule happens to be
for the United States Centers
for Disease Control, the CDC.
But there's also [the]
one-meter rule, which
is basically a three-foot
rule, for the World Health
Organization.
So this is not
extremely well defined,
what should be the distance.
But clearly, if you are able
to stay away from people,
then even if they're
coughing or breathing
these large droplets with only
a few seconds of settling time,
those droplets
will hit the floor.
And it will not be able
to infect you directly.
And so it's
important to maintain
that kind of distancing.
OK.
Now there are also other
kinds of bacteria that don't
form these larger colonies.
And they remain small even
when they're transmitting.
And a classic
example of that which
can be transmitted in small
drops is tuberculosis.
In fact, the original
study in the 1930s --
also involving wells -- was for --
that led to this --
essentially the distancing
rules and the six-foot rule
in particular -- had to do
with coughing and sneezing
and the distance over which
droplets could be transmitted
containing tuberculosis.
Now tuberculosis
on the other hand,
as you can see in
the image, is a sort
of rod like bacteria
that's quite small.
So the length is several
microns, typically two to four.
But the radius is half a micron
or even down to 0.2 microns.
So actually, we're really
talking about hundreds
of nanometers in length.
So these are kind of
little rods like this.
And they can be contained
in a pretty small droplet.
These big colonies of course,
require something much larger.
So these droplets
could be small.
And so there is a
possibility here
of larger aerosol transmission.
By larger, I mean in the
range of 5 to 10 microns.
So of course
tuberculosis also can
be contained in much
larger droplets, which,
you know, fall to the ground
as we've just been describing,
but tuberculosis
is a bit different
in that these individual
bacteria could
be transmitted airborne in
larger aerosol droplets.
And in fact, that
is what is found.
If you have this
size of droplet,
then it turns out, for
example, if my radius is
let's say greater
than 4 microns,
then the settling
velocity you can
find given the density of
aqueous fluids, is around 2 --
bigger than 2
millimeters a second.
And then the time to drop
from a typical person's height
to the ground is
around 15 minutes.
So these are not
the kind of aerosols
that might stick
around for hours
like the sub-micron
aerosols that are also
produced by breathing
and which are too
small to contain tuberculosis.
But still, these times
suggests that tuberculosis
can linger in the air.
And in fact, long distance
airborne transmission
is not only possible
as we've just
argued based on physical
grounds, but it's
been directly verified.
That's been done both
in humans studies
and also in animal studies.
Where they can have two
different compartments with
a sick animal, such as a ferret
or some other animal model,
and the disease is
spread to another animal
who's had no direct contact
but is sharing the same air.
So the airborne
transmission is definitely
verified in this case.
And now you might
ask, well, what
are the preventive measures?
So instead of all
of these measures,
like plastic shields
and six-foot rule,
if you're actually
airborne transmission --
if there is a
shield, then the air
is going to go right
around the shield.
And it's going to go
everywhere else in the room,
because the air is flowing.
In the same way that when
you light a candle and you
see where the smoke
is going, it quickly
spreads around the whole room.
It doesn't care if
there's a shield there.
As long as there is a
way around the shield,
that's going to find that.
And so instead,
when you're trying
to protect against
airborne transmission,
your protective measures
are things like ventilation,
so bring in fresh
air from outside
or opening your windows;
air filtration, where
you're passing the air
through a filter which
is going to filter out
the particles by size or by
charge or some other mechanism
like that;
and also it becomes
more and more
important to wear face masks
because then at least you
can block these droplets
at the source and
also at the target,
as we shall discuss
in much more detail.
So what we see here
is just knowing simply
the size of the pathogen
and understanding
the physics of
droplets in the air,
helps us to understand
the modes of transmission,
which are written here in blue.
and also, the appropriate
protective measures,
which are written here in pink,
to protect against
these different types
of transmission.